- C'est le passage obligé pour
tous les juges sont nommés
Subir un interrogatoire
interminable des sénateu
Tous les thèmes sont abordés, la
théorie critique de la race, son
mari et même ssasasasasasasasas.
Les républicains ne la ménagent
pas.
Imperturbable, Ketanji Brown
Jackson répond calmement aux
questions.
Vous ne lui avez donné que trois
mois
- En tant que mère et juger,
vous êtes loin de la vérité,
sont les dossiers les plus
difficiles.
On lui reproche d'avoir... alors
ministres d'aide juridique.
Ça m'est égal si leenenenenenus
meurent à Guantanamo lancent
sénateurs.
Pourquoi avoir prêté l'ancien
secrétaire à la défense, des
criminels de guerre demandent le
référence, dit-elle.
Elle d d d d des crimes de
elle est d'accord avec la
crcrcrcrcrcritique de la race.es
livres qui disent que les butée.
- Aucun enfant ne devrait seacau
qu'il n'est pas valorisé, dit-e.
Peu importe les queleleleleleles
parti de la première génération
a bénéficié des mouvements des
droits civiques pour que des
gens comme moieveveveveveveveve.
- Quand le vote final va
arriver, et  c c c c c c c c c e
vais me réjouir, car le pays
sera mieux grâce à des gens
comme vo
- Inébranlable depuis le début,
elle craque à ce moment.KeKeKeKa
position de la cou